what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to eminem 25 to life
before i start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel bring that notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily
videos leave a comment let me know what
music video you want me to react to next
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
i don't think she understands the
sacrifices that i made maybe if this
[ __ ] had acted right i would have
stayed but i've already wasted over half
my life i would have laid down and tied
for you i no longer cried for you no
more pain [ __ ] you took me for granted
took my heart and ran it straightened to
the planet into the dirt i can no longer
stand it never i'm surprised i've never
heard of this song before one of my
subscribers reacted
or requested it from me
because i like it like so far
he's so hurt poor i'm enough respect i
demand it i'm gonna take control of this
relationship command it and i'm gonna be
the boss of you now goddammit and what i
mean is that i will no longer let you
control me so you better hear me out
this much you owe me i gave up my life
for you totally devoted to you i've
stayed thankful all the way this is how
i [ __ ] get regained look at how i
dress [ __ ] baggy sweats go to work a
mess always send a rust to get back to
you i heard you yet not even
[Music]
okay so this in a song kind of embodies
what i hear about like in the manosphere
which is just basically that there's a
bunch of entitled women that like don't
do anything with their lives
but you keep treating me like a
staircase it's time to [ __ ] step and
i will be coming back so don't hold your
[ __ ] breath you know what you've done
[Music]
it's unfortunate but
[Music]
the girls
[Music]
fall myself in half till i snap don't
think i'm loyal all i do is rap why
can't i move light on the side i have no
life outside of that don't i give you
enough of my time you don't think so do
you jealous when i spend time with the
girls why i'm married to you still man i
don't know but tonight i'm serving you
with papers i'm divorcing you go married
make him famous and take away oh damn
he said it is over
i'm serving you with the divorce papers
oh man
when i was with you all i ever felt was
this helplessness
myself his [ __ ] chewed me up and spit
me out i felt but it so many times it's
ridiculous and still i stick with this
i'm sick of this but in my sickness and
addiction your addictive is naked evil
as they come vindictive as they make
them my friends keep asking me why i
can't just walk away from i'm addicted
to the pain the stress the drama i'm
drawing should i guess i'm a mess cursed
and blessed but this time i ain't
changing my mind i'm climbing up this
abyss you're screaming as i walk out
that i'll be missing but when you spoke
of people who made the most to you you
left me off your list [ __ ] you hip-hop
i'm leaving you my life sentence is
served [ __ ] and it's just
[Music]
okay i don't get it too late for the
other side caught in a chase 25 to life
that sounds like a prison sentence is he
saying the relationship is a prison
oh no he died oh he's okay
he's good he got up
[Music]
oh it's not over okay
[Music]
okay i
am surprised because i don't typically
like eminem that much
but i would for real give this video a
five out of five like in terms of the
music the music video was okay i didn't
really understand what was going on
but like
yeah that was fire um let me know in the
comments what you guys think
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
ring that notification bell
i'll talk to you guys next time